you ended up uh working with mozzie
which uh obviously free mozzie yeah I
think I put you guys on text together
the day we did that interview yeah um
you tell you told me you're still
keeping in contact with him you wrote
him in jail like talk about your guys's
relationship fast forward a year and
some change man so it's so crazy because
we did our interview here you asked me
who I would work with if I could work
with anybody I said Mozzy this was
before meeting him following on social
media anything
so
yeah somehow we got we got in in touch I
think like I put you guys on a group
chat yeah and then on the spot yeah and
then a month later it happened I came to
Cali
I remember at the interview you were
like and it's the most people I've ever
seen in my studio I had like my whole
neighborhood with me when we went into
his [__] we went into his studio
and he did the song on the spot and then
he was like what y'all doing after let's
shoot the video which like a rapper
never says to you yeah nobody ever wants
to shoot the video Kiss actually said to
me he was like damn when's the last time
you did a song for a rapper that you're
bigger than and then asked him to shoot
the video no you were like yeah he was
like I was like yeah he was like man you
got to appreciate that type of [__] so
yeah we did that and that's a classic
song for me Kev like that [__] rings off
in London that [__] rings off in L.A New
York Boston I mean they sing that [__]
that's big bro yeah shout out Mozzy man
real guy somebody else who's kind of a
white guy speaking about Street [__]
that's doing well right now is OT shout
out to OT the real yeah
um I know you guys have uh have worked
together what's uh
would you guys ever do a joint project
together or would that be a little too
expected
um no I would do a joint project with
him definitely when the time is right
because he's hard bro yeah he's one of
them MC's like when you're a high level
rapper
it's a difference from doing songs with
you know certain people certain people
you really gotta lock in like you can't
[__] with them there's certain
rappers I could get in the studio I
don't really gotta give you the craziest
[__] because I'm gonna still be top tier
up here without trying [__] with
somebody who's like this you gotta
really like lock in and pay attention
like if you listen to our back and forth
song everybody should go listen to that
that's I forget what it's called but go
listen to it and um you know that's like
verbal sparring that's just fire would
you and Dave doing a sequel tier yeah
yeah we're working on that you're
working on it yeah we're working on that
nice he just sent me the first record
for real I like it man who else from
your area or Boston just I guess kind of
just that whole area would you uh say is
on the come up that you're [__] with
that we can shut some light on
um I'm gonna say that there's a there's
a there's a lot of people but I'm gonna
say Gene Nipsey for sure
um he's in here right now he's going
crazy
um he really had my city like my city
was already
feeling them involved and there's a lot
of kids from my city that kind of like
get mad at that like why you don't
support me too but I'm like you got to
get the city first get the city you know
so um yeah D Nipsey going crazy died of
the deal of my man um jigs
and then uh man there's a lot of rappers
out of the trenches in Boston that are
going crazy obviously the the bigger
ones too like beer and you know Joyner
he is like a OG too people don't people
think she just popped off I'm like B has
been now we yeah that's what I'm saying
we if you look at Massachusetts the
rappers we all had the longest roads
yeah be it had a long road man the label
damage
Joyner had a long I had a long road B I
had a long road because if you're from
Massachusetts you got to work three
times as hard because it's never been
done